hey what's up how are you excellent
really happy to be here with you how you
been
good you know just getting through it
all right i mean how about you
you know what same seas
we're both smiling so i mean that says
something right
it can't be that bad for so smiling
right but no i mean we're going
we're doing good we're doing good i mean
i think it's
it's all perspective at this point right
i think that the initial shock of like
what is life gonna be
and all of those questions that were a
little too deep too fast
yeah i think they kind of wore off a
little bit now it's just kind of
waiting it out doing the protocol and
being responsible and that's kind of
where we're at but uh
i don't know so many good things that
also have come out of this thing right
so i i feel like
there's just a different different
energy uh
specifically at home with the families
and relationships of this like that i
think
that that's something that's uplifting
for sure yeah your priorities change
right i have two kids at home and
the silver lining is seeing them growing
up time i've never had before with them
so i know that
there's this beautiful feeling of that
and for you to be able to create a show
at a time like that content for people
who are you know they need a little joy
in their lives
that must be pretty spectacular yeah you
know at the beginning
i don't think anyone expected that film
television and just entertainment in
general was going to be
so incredibly clutch
like it was like a moment where people
were catching up on shows they've kind
of given up on for a minute
they decided oh you know what i want to
watch that the first two seasons of my
favorite show that i watched like 10
years ago
and and then all the new content that
was available at that time that was that
was kind of an exciting thing but i
think you're right i think i feel like
it's also a very rewarding thing uh the
first day we returned to set a couple of
months ago
um you know we were introduced to a a
world of protocols that you know you
can't even imagine right just to be on
set
and to be able to work with 300 people
in the same
it was a really interesting song and
dance but i would say that
it was an emotional moment it was an
emotional day because we realized how
one we were putting ourselves in arm's
way right we couldn't just
you know we were one of the few
industries that can that could return to
work
um and number two we realized the
importance of
of getting back into people's homes uh
that was like i feel like a very humble
small contribution
that we actors and directors and
producers and writers could do
in order to keep us uh with some kind of
sanity so
um so we thought it was important and
therefore you know we we followed
protocols
religiously and making sure that you
know that we that we pulled it off and
now
you know we're we're on episode nine or
ten i don't know what episode
people jumped up so quickly into the
season talking about gibbs and purnell's
off book investigation and people like
what is going to happen
into january can you give us a little
bit of an indication where that
storyline is going to go
yeah i mean i think i think you're going
to discover
a lot of things about gibbs um you know
he he has you know as you guys know
people talk
about gabe's rules you know yeah
i think you're gonna you're gonna find
that gif's rules are
going to be um challenged by himself
um i think that he's gonna break a lot
of rules this season i think that he's
going to
uh enlist uh his team
you know mcgee bishop torres uh
you know palmer and uh um
and casey into uh and to a different
world uh
and they're they're gonna have to bend
the rules themselves in order to do
things uh outside of the office outside
of the book
you know so i mean i think that that's
an interesting fun place for the ncs to
go you know ncis has been
the following rules you know and but uh
there
are times in your in your time uh as a
man of service and a woman of service
that
you're gonna have to bend some rules in
order to achieve the same outcome
yeah oh i like that yeah it's it's an
exciting new beginning but i also think
you know i always i always think it's so
fascinating
how the writers are able to keep it so
fresh right and
they've also made a real partnership
with us on on the show so a lot of them
really consult with the actors where do
you think your character will go next
how is this
how does the character feel about this
object oh that's good
yeah you know and we've done a lot of
work on our our characters
so it makes it fun for us to continue to
be um involved and and uh
and also for us invested to perform
those themes
and so does that mean bishop and torres
are going to create a new chemistry
going forward into
january will they kind of become that
relationship
everyone's waiting for um
you know i think i can exclusively say
this to
you that we're definitely going to
explore um what these characters are
are going to go next um but i mean i and
i
i keep saying this and i feel like i
sound like a broken record when i say
this
the last thing i want to do is something
that shows a scene before
i don't want to do a storyline that the
show has done before i don't i don't
people want it wilmer they understand
what's that relationship you gotta make
it happen
tell me now yes it is going to happen
i'm all out for giving the audience what
they want okay exactly
but it's important to me that we do
something that i
that is different you know when you look
at two characters who are just not good
at relationships
and you you want them together and
you're rooting for them to be
each other's salvation maybe she gets
pregnant
i'm not gonna say she doesn't and i'm
not gonna say she did
we're actually announcing that mori is
going to be uh guest starring on the
show so
he's going to be doing a lot of the he
is the baby
um but um i don't know you know i think
i think that going back to your question
i think we are we're definitely going to
explore the relationship we're gonna
figure out where it goes you know and
we're gonna find a really fun unique way
to
introduce it you know again these are
travel trouble souls you know these are
trouble individuals that
have had to do so many things to be just
to do their job you know and i think
that
that's kind of playing a factor on um
where they go from here
and the holidays are just around the
corner i know it feels different this
year but
what's your wish for the holidays what
it's a heavy question but you know what
what is on your mind
you know what's on my mind i want my
family to be a little more at
ease you know i want them to go into
2021 knowing that there's a solution
around the corner that my mom is going
to be able to take her
regular little walk to the grocery store
without you know having to
glove up and double mask up just to go
get her little vegetables you know
i want i want i want that certainty i
want that that
confidence to come back into all
families you know
and i yeah i'm working with a lot of our
colleagues you know to raise awareness
for not just protocols but you know how
to
keep each other safe and i think as we
wait for this possible vaccine and
figure out what it means for the world
and you know and what it does for our
sanity yeah i think we have to kind of
hang on to one another tighter than so
this christmas
we're locking it down we're being
responsible we're not having
we're not having any family travel we're
not having family come visit us or
anything like that so we're you know
we're gonna just kind of lock it down
and be responsible and you know
hopefully set it right as an example for
people to know that
one christmas out of you know many um
exactly lock it down a little bit it's
okay to have to
wash that many dishes you know exactly
just order food this time around
uh you know i have to say as a canadian
woman justin bieber you're
you made a cameo in his video holy how
did that even
happen did you call justin bieber go hey
i want to hang out with you like
like how did like seriously how did that
even happen
well you know uh scooter braun is one of
my closest friends he's like a brother
of mine since we were in our early
childhood
wow and scooter and i have always
um support each other and help each
other then i met justin when he was
really really young
uh and i've seen his evolution as a
young man and
i know his heart and i really really
love the kid and he's he's
just uh he's he's uh he's a he's a real
man and i think that he's on up to so
much of his life and i think that
his next chapter his new era is an
exciting one so
when when scooter called me he's like
hey justin and chance the rapper
are just they just want you in this
music video there's a storyline can you
talk to our director i was like all
right let me let me figure it out and i
and i talked to the director and
i love what the the song was um yeah i
love the premise of the video
and i really thought to myself at a time
where we need a little bit more hope
and a little more confirmation that we
can truly reach out to one another
and excuse me that we truly can reach
out to one another and uplift each other
um i felt this video had the right
message and um
you know the fact that i could be uh you
know a person of color wearing the
uniform and having the you know the
iconic returning to home
you know image um that was important to
me it was important to play a latino
wearing a uniform because
um you know we often forget that
there's so many of our minority
communities you know waving the flag
proudly um and uh and we're in the
uniform proudly
and uh and doing what they can just to
to protect all of us so
so to me that was that was an honor to
play men and women of the uniform and be
able to represent the music video was
great so
but i love what he did and i felt like
it was effective i got a lot of videos
from fans crying watching it you know
yeah yeah it's beautiful it's beautiful
to know when it works right and we
worked
hard i mean and justin and i worked uh
justin
ryan and i brian played his wife in the
video we worked really hard at all those
little scenes and we improvised all of
that stuff we wrote it in the moment and
we made sure that
that even though a lot of it was going
to be the music video and the music
yeah usually that something was really
happening you know so we had all the
lines and the scenes and everything and
we played the scenes
to my surprise they used some of some of
that dialogue and that was kind of fun
um
but um but yeah i mean we worked hard
and justin is super talented so he got
it in two seconds and
and we did something i think we're gonna
be proud for a long time